honorable members mr browder
lawrence of the nobel peace prize and
the sarah of prize
distinguished guests
when innocent men and women get killed
nothing can bring them back nothing
can bring back sergey magnitsky
but there are things we can do to honor
his memory
we can hold accountable those who
violate the most basic human rights
we can act so that crimes like
magnitsky's death
do not happen again and this is why we
meet today
even if just virtually
europe has the power to make a
difference on the protection of human
rights
we have the power to sanction a crime
that is committed
outside our borders we have the power to
prevent
some crimes and not to forget the power
to make positive change happen
in some cases europe has already used
this power
two years ago for instance the european
union
sanctioned a group of burmese generals
they were responsible for the killing of
tens of
thousands of people from the rohingya
minority
so europe decided to freeze their assets
and to prevent them from entering the
european union
the day after we agreed on the sanctions
the government of myanmar removed those
generals from their posts
european sanctions had a clear impact
sanctions can make a difference as a
foreign policy tool
as a deterrent but most
importantly as a signal that europe does
act in the face of injustice
human rights must be sacred everywhere
from belarus to syria from myanmar to
venezuela
from russia to china
it shouldn't matter where the violation
took place
if there is a crime europe must have the
tools to act
and this is why a global eu human rights
sanctions regime was an important
announcement
in my state of the union address
and last month we have put forward our
proposal for the magnitsky act
which is now to be approved by european
governments
it can be a sea change for european
foreign affairs
up to now whenever we wanted to impose
new sanctions
we have to create a new legal framework
specific to the country and the
situation in question
and this can take a lot of precious time
and far too often we have seen that
simple decisions get stuck or delayed
for reasons having nothing to do with
human rights
so this has to change i want europe to
step up
i want europe to act quickly when human
rights are at stake
the european voice matters
and early and decisive action can
prevent further harm
so this is why we now propose a
framework for sanctions
that is global in scope the magnitsky
act
it is a strong tool
it is very often the case that those
responsible for human rights violations
are wealthy and powerful they benefit
from insecurity and undemocratic
structures in their
country but they themselves
like to take advantage of the
hospitality
of safe and democratic countries like in
the european union
and this is where we can sanction them
the sanctions regime includes the
possibility to impose travel bans
alongside with the freezing of financial
assets
human rights violations will have a high
cost for those who are responsible
it is now up to the member states of our
union to take the final decision
it is time to send a clear message to
the world
because when human rights are under
attack
i want europe to take clear positions
to defend human rights defenders to be
on the right side europe has the size
and the power to make a difference for
human rights
worldwide it is only up to us
to use that power thank you